we used to watch Disney Channel every
day when we were kids and the actresses
that we once knew are now more popular
than ever but as we grew up we realized
that this channel was not as good as it
was before are we too old or is it just
really bad we think that Disney won't
last that long if they don't get better
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know why television is over if
you listen to Disney Channel you know
what we are talking about so make sure
you like this video and subscribe for
more stories like this today we are
showing you everything wrong with the
Disney Channel it all almost started in
1977 when Jim Jumeirah said that Walt
Disney Productions should have their own
television channel and it ended there as
Disney's Chairman turned down the
proposal but Disney tried again in 1983
and it was finally the right time to do
it they invested 11 million dollars on
two communication satellites and 20
million dollars on programming the same
year the family oriented cable channel
was launched Disney was ready to be more
popular than ever by entering people's
homes through their television screen
Disney used to be a premium channel
targeted to kids and teenagers during
the day families during primetime and
adults during the night everyone was
happy and it is great to see that
grownups used to love watching Disney
Channel too but unfortunately things
changed over time since Disney began
targeting itself as a basic Channel
shows for young adults are not really
popular anymore
even teenagers think that the shows are
sometimes really childish people if
their age don't live the same thing that
the characters do Joe Jonas the actor
himself admitted that he had to pretend
that he was younger for a show for kids
he said that it ended up with some
slapstick humor that only a ten-year-old
can laugh at and that the show was badly
written in 1983 we could watch shows
like Good Morning Mickey
welcome to the poop corner Asterix and
Donald Duck presents with funny
characters that anyone still remembers
nowadays even though we watch them three
decades ago but Disney Channel shows are
not watched by every generation of kids
anymore
there is no brand loyalty the best shows
last for three or four seasons before
they are canceled and quickly forgotten
their stars move on to something else as
they grow up and are replaced by
Newlands
this is why grown-ups are missing the
chance to see characters that they used
to love when they watch television with
their children shows used to last for
decades but Disney is now making cheaper
shows that are quickly replaced by
another trend some of the best shows
lasted only for a few years like good
luck charlie for four years shake it up
for three years and Liv and Maddie for
four years this is barely anything
compared to the 89 year old Mickey Mouse
and the iconic Disney Princesses we lost
the classics that made Disney eternal
and enjoyable to watch for every
generation another problem is that
Disney Channel is staying in the past it
is way too conservative that's because
they are listening to the parents who
complain that the shows are not
appropriate for their kids for example
some of them say that Disney is teaching
kids that they should not listen to
their parents they also think that some
jokes are really inappropriate even
though only grownups who already made
jokes like that can understand it some
of them even complain that some girls
were too interested in boys even though
this is totally normal for any teenager
Disney wants to please the parents but
most teenagers think that it doesn't
make sense that characters their age
always listen to their parents don't do
anything inappropriate and just want to
kiss their boyfriend with characters
that teenagers can't relate to only kids
are watching these shows thinking that
they will be like that when they grow up
but they are not prepared for what is
really going to happen in their life and
this is not the worst thing that Disney
did because they wanted to make everyone
happy it is only in 2014 that we saw the
first gay characters on Disney Channel
when good luck charlie featured two
lesbian moms it was a good step forward
but we still think that Disney should
have done this way earlier to show kids
that it is totally normal to be gay they
even told TV Guide that the episode was
developed to be relevant to kids and
families around the world and to reflect
themes of diversity and inclusiveness
but when we see how parents react we
totally understand why they did this the
group 1 Million Moms reacted a letter
and said that they asked Disney to
abandon their plans to corrupt the
children's network with LGBT content but
Disney has decided to be politically
correct instead of providing
family-friendly programming
Disney should stick to entertaining not
pushing an agenda and they are not the
only ones who reacted this way when we
hear this we understand why Disney
didn't want to feature gay characters in
2017 we even have
the chance to watch the first gay
storyline in Andy Mack it took way too
much time and we wished that Disney
would have done this before as they have
such a big influence on children who has
the biggest influence on Disney Channel
it is probably the stars since the
all-new Mickey Mouse Club in 1989 we met
future celebrities like Christina
Aguilera Ryan Gosling Britney Spears
Justin Timberlake and many others they
all grow up to be amazing artists that
we still remember nowadays Disney stars
are still more popular than ever if you
take for example Miley Cyrus Selena
Gomez Bella Thorne and much more but if
they have one thing in common it is that
these young stars all became bad at
least according to Disney Channel and
today we will find out why some actors
like brenda song support disney saying
that they are grateful for these
opportunities and she knows that they
always believed in her but those who are
more popular had to admit that working
for the Disney Channel was not really a
dream come true Miley said that the only
reason why she loved Disney is that she
didn't know anything else the singer
realized when she was older that it was
a lot to put on a kid and not being able
to separate the two worlds cause some
serious psychological damages she also
suffered from body image issues while
filming Hannah Montana because she felt
like she didn't meet the expectations to
be a pop star and she had to wear a wig
and a ton of makeup this is where she
lived all her teenage years and she was
on set wearing white pants while she had
her first period she was crying and had
to ask her mom to put the tampon in
because she couldn't do it herself which
is something that you should never live
in work if Kelli Berglund said your
awkward years are put in the spotlight
for the world to see and that's really
hard to live Nick from the Jonas
Brothers said that Disney felt like a
summer camp but there was also a lot of
drama like it happens in high school
Selena Gomez agreed with him when she
said it was everything that any teen
goes through just on a bigger scale it
was literally like high school Selena is
another actress who grew up in the
spotlight and she said that she wouldn't
recommend it to anyone she thinks that
it is really dysfunctional to be in this
industry at a young age where you are
figuring out who you are
anytime she did something wrong it hurt
her feelings bella thorne also revealed
that she was forced to compete with her
co-star zendaya on shake it up for a
whole season until the two girls talked
to each other but this is nothing
compared to what debby ryan did to her
co-star Skye Jackson on Jessie the two
girls used to be really close
and the actress even said in an
interview that Debbie Ryan was fantastic
and she loved to have her but then in
2014 Skyy unfollowed Debbie on Twitter
it was explained a year later when Skyy
accused her co-star of being a bully and
it was all happening on the actresses
secret Twitter account it was confirmed
when Skye tweeted that she was not rude
to Debbie it was the other way around
the older actors replied by saying that
if she were 12 she probably would be
insecure about the lead of the show -
not to mention if she was the concept a
producer and one of the directors were
the most assignment requests she then
said that she won't speak on specific
people because it is unprofessional but
if she had one wish for every child
actor especially those that tend to be
the mouthpiece for parental
maliciousness she'd wish for complete
contentment emotional security that
they'd somehow find the joy in telling
stories we don't know about you but we
think that this popularity and this
power made Debbie Ryan crazy some actors
did have better things to say but we
should not forgive what Disney did to
their other stars if they didn't do what
they wanted them to do they were in
trouble and this is why a Jonas Brother
decided to reveal how Disney puppet
masters control their teen stars Joe
Jonah's always wanted to be a singer but
everything changed when Disney entered
the picture he had to admit that Disney
is the reason why the Jonas Brothers
became so popular and they are great at
creating fame but being part of the
Disney machine came with a cost they had
a younger audience which means that they
had to make music for kids and be
perfect role models as we have heard
before Joe Jonas was way too old to play
this kind of role and thought that the
writing was terrible even though he was
a Disney star he his brothers thought
that Disney was their real shot and they
were terrified that it could be taken
away from them at any moment the singer
was feeling a lot of pressure that came
from certain expectations he heard about
the Vanessa Hudgens nude photo scandal
and knew that she was really in trouble
and didn't want the same thing to happen
to them Disney kept telling them that
they were proud of the Jonas Brothers
for not making any mistake which made
them feel like they could never mess up
and they put an incredible pressure on
themselves this is why many Disney stars
want to break their contract and a
youtuber thinks that he knows how they
are doing this Shane Dawson loves
conspiracy theories and once again he
wanted to talk about Disney stars or
more specifically why they go crazy the
problem is that every Disney personality
signs a lengthy contract and agree that
Disney kind of owned
them for a long time it looks like a
dream but then these actors grow up and
don't want to be part of the Disney
machine anymore they can't sue because
Disney will obviously win the Kansas
asked politely either because there is a
reason why Disney wants to control them
the only thing they can do is make sure
that Disney won't want to work with them
again this is why their female stars
start releasing nude pictures dressed
provocatively and sing about sex
Hilary Duff said that people still saw
her as Lizzie McGuire five years after
the end of the show and she was tired of
being remembered for her sixth-grade
self Ross Lynch also said that people
start to think that because you come
from Disney that you're a certain way
you're perceived to be such an angel and
really you're just an actor that booked
the job according to Shane Dawson Disney
stars go crazy so they won't be
associated with Disney any more it works
so well that he thinks that dove Cameron
will have to do the same thing too if
she wants to hand to her contract with
Disney jake paul the popular youtuber is
one of those who just became crazies he
keeps doing crazy pranks was accused of
being a bully and clearly annoyed his
neighbors this is probably the reason
why he was fired from Biz aardvark on
Disney Channel Disney wanted to pretend
that it was a common agreement to make
themselves look better but the
social-media influencer finally told the
truth anyway Jake Paul said that he was
too old for all this and wanted to focus
on playing more adult roles the 22 year
old is not interested in playing a 16
year old and we totally understand this
Jake wanted to focus on his career as a
youtuber and we think that this is a
great thing to do
that's because television is over and
Disney won't last long if they stay on
the cable and don't move to the Internet
in the past three years Disney Channel
has lost about 4 million subscribers the
problem is that audiences are moving
away from traditional television because
they are more interested in digital
alternatives with streaming services
like Netflix YouTube Hulu and Amazon
people can watch whatever they want
whenever they want and wherever they
want people are not interested in
sitting in front of the TV at the right
time and on the right day to watch their
favorite show and then wait a whole week
to watch the next episode more and more
kids are growing up with streaming
services and they are not interested in
traditional televisions anymore
unless they still live with their
parents the youngest generation doesn't
have a television screen in their first
apartment anymore
fans also want to feel closer to their
favorite stars and this is exactly what
they can do on
you too with the likes and the comments
videos online keep changing to follow
the latest trends while traditional
television has stayed the same for
several decades disney channel president
said that they see the migration and one
of the challenges is trying to serve the
viewership where they're going as
opposed to trying to drive them where we
want them to go we think that they are
going to have to act much faster if they
don't want to lose their fans because
many of them are right there online
watching this video if we could watch
Disney Channel online we think that it
would easily convince us to watch it
again just to make things clear we are
not saying that we don't like Disney
Channel we just think that it could be
better in many ways and there are some
things that need to be improved if they
want to stay popular don't worry we'll
keep watching the shows and talking
about our favorite Disney stars is there
anything wrong that we forgot to talk
about don't be shy to tell us what it is
in the comment section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for everything wrong with the Disney
Channel for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 strange reasons why
Disney movies were banned thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]